I just want to say it's a real thrill to
talk to you guys obviously like the rest
of the planet I love Tetris and uh I
thought this movie was so well done I'm
really happy to talk to you guys
um so I guess my first question is going
to be the most important uh I am curious
for the two of you what level can you
actually get to on the Game Boy in
Tetris you don't have any anything
behind you they told me I couldn't do
that I see
okay so I uh I saw the law the the
rocket launch once
in the in the end game boy version you
mean the shuttle shuttle yeah the
shuttle is the the last roll ask yes
yeah I did it once
yeah that's what that's my level who was
the Game Boy I can I can pretty much get
the shuttle to come out whenever I want
obviously Tetris has been released on
many different uh and it's been released
on every console mobile every format uh
do you guys actually have a favorite
version that you like to play uh whether
it be on the Nintendo or in the arcade
I'm just curious my my personal
preference is always the computer I like
those those buttons because because I I
did play a lot while I developed the
game and debugged it and and and the the
first five years of my my life with the
game was was related to computer so my
prefer my preferable kind of interface
is computer so I like every computer
version what about here yeah so
um you know I like the game boy version
it's sort of the classic Tetris it
became the classic textures when people
look back on the history of Tetris they
think that's the first incentive but
actually there was a bunch of them
before
so Game Boy is good
um it's not often that I get to work on
on a game myself uh and at a certain
point uh where I was licensing Tetris to
other companies and we wanted to create
an example of this is Tetris beat that
and so we created a version called
Tetris Zone
but it wasn't like released because uh
it was just an internal product it was
just to show the other licensees uh how
and so I got to have lots of my ideas I
think that's what we did uh t-spin for
the first time
um yeah but but that's that's kind of
individual individual long-term play as
far as game experiences concerned I am
really excited about Tetris night
tonight it's it's absolutely great
experience for for kind of the
sentimental part you know I think I
think the most creative uh version of
Tetris you know he's talking about
gameplay which is of course important
but there's a there's Tetris effect
uh the tetris effect which is made by
multimedia genius uh that's a VR Tetris
and uh no hidden I don't know if it's
where it's been released it must be
released everywhere yeah it's like I I
played it on computer done on
Playstation no
it it is it is original version that as
well but I do remember my experience is
on computer
anyway Alexa you have uh created a
number of other games besides Tetris uh
and I'm curious if someone has not
played any of the other things you've
created what's the one or two other
games you think they should check out
well I'm not sure it's available now but
but the game I'm really proud of is
Pandora's Box the it's a it's a big
title I I came out while I work at
Microsoft
I I try to I try to bring the the puzzle
spirit in the world and I kind of invent
in my white I invent the new type of the
fossils the visual puzzles which I
really emphasize in in this title and
that was a it was pretty good title I
I'm always ahead of time unfortunately
oh my gear all my titles are little bit
more original than than it should be at
at that time so so I don't I don't see
very big big response while I came up
with the game and I see uh and they see
their their
five six seven here after after my first
release that's what's happening most of
my career
is pretty good game uh not not the best
realization but but the game itself has
a has a big meaning inside it it's it's
it's kind of my vision on on kind of
Bejeweled mechanics I will put it this
way I definitely want to jump into the
movie uh I can't imagine what it was
like for the two of you watching this on
the screen for the first time so I just
want to know what was it like sitting in
that theater and taking it in because I
just can't imagine well for me I I
remember I cried several times during
the movie and I don't I don't cry easily
but I was moved you know there was a
there was the bit where I come home uh
or my wife comes home with my daughter
and she she has the same oh my gosh that
was so touching uh so
how can you not cry during that scene
but uh yeah I was
you know I was I don't know I was blown
away by the Moby it's a movie
sure not just it's not a documentary
it's a movie and it's a story and you
want to call it a thriller on steroids
whatever you want to call it it's a
movie it's a real movie
yeah uh and uh yes and I feel I feel
very proud of my game you know
this is a movie about the address and uh
and uh and the the fact that they they
take the most important uh most
important moment of the business life of
my game is is so is so touching for me
so so finally finally the the very small
kind of stuff which you which you which
you the which takes a couple moment of
your time now it's on the screen it's a
it's in a big culture that make me
really proud I'm curious what do you
think audiences when they see the movie
will in in the film will think is like
Hollywood make believe magic but
actually really happened it's a I guess
there's not many people who've had a
movie email made about their life while
they're still alive
you know so so
um
yes there were things that happened uh
yes there were things that that happened
in the movie that you know they took uh
artistic license
uh but there are things that they left
that they couldn't fit into the movie
that would have been the equivalent so
what they did is take take a year and a
half of my life squeeze it into two
hours and get the point across and and I
think they did that wonderfully one of
the things that I was so surprised at is
you managed to do or um elog elorg only
license the game for 10 years and I'm
just curious how did you pull this off
in terms of
um only letting you know the 10-year
license I'm sure that more companies
were asking we want more than 10 years
yeah no so so in the in the business
nobody has a spreadsheet that lasts more
than 10 years nobody thinks that far
into the future so when we were sitting
in that room negotiating that it was was
Nintendo was in the room I was in the
room like she was in the room and we're
all negotiating and and they're gonna
have have a big fight with Atari tari
games but they needed right of title
going back to the author and they
created this document documentation
going all the way back to Alexi and and
they made it for a period of 10 years
because nobody thought it was going to
be an issue after 10 years you know that
we're we're they thought it would be
gone by then nobody had that
understanding the GL you know that it
would last long or be even growing after
that so yeah that was we were pretty
lucky in that
um so in 95 the rights reverted I had a
big battle with the Lord for about a
year and we finally settled and made the
tetris company yeah it's it's uh it is
true though that generally speaking it's
very very very few games that are still
being played 10 years after you have to
be something special yes and I'm
wondering why
I mean I mean the game is very software
product but it's still very
psychological stuff the software and
Hardware change but our brain remained
the same and what brings you lots of
pleasure keep bringing it to you and and
other human beings so so the the that's
why I never expect Tetris to be gone
because it's a really good cave you know
why why why why
you you you don't come back to it so
it's it's still it's still big mystery
for me why several really great gifts
are gone already I I mean they they they
they they will come back I'm pretty sure
I listen I don't have an answer except
to say that I was when I was preparing
to talk to the two of you I went to the
tetris website and they have the game on
the home page and I then started playing
and the next thing you know I'm sitting
there for 20 minutes playing the game
it's just it's like it's like a you know
it's um you know it's uh yeah it's uh
you know you know but actually I want to
ask you guys I believe next year is the
40th anniversary of the game and I
wanted to know if you guys are planning
anything special well we'll work on the
brand really hard and probably we will
have the
the the the the good version the updated
version coming out on several platforms
yeah my my daughter Maya is in charge of
uh running things now and I'm sure she's
she's cooking really hard you know I I'm
I've sort of back backed off the
business end of it uh she's smarter than
I am so she uh she she knows what she's
doing and uh I'm sure she's got
something really great happening next
year Hank you are known for uh being
able to talk your way in and out of
situations and I'm curious what's a
situation that you talked your way in or
out of that you still can't believe you
did it oh my goodness
no this is I mean the movie is that it
it it's the the one what's the other
situation oh my gosh my first meeting
with Yamauchi uh I I went to Nintendo
after my wife read an article that the
Emoji plays go and I talked myself into
becoming a publisher
in like half an hour you know it's it's
uh wow what do you think also back then
though
um I believe this must have been the 80s
was it it must have been just a
completely different world in the video
game industry versus what it is now it
was such the infancy of the whole Market
yeah when you when you think about
um the history
I started my first company by writing a
role-playing game by myself did all the
graphics did all the story did all the
programming did all the marketing did
all the sales I mean I pretty much did
everything and that's you could do that
back then today it's like to do that
same kind of thing a team of a hundred
people if not more uh
it's just Unthinkable but it's uh yeah
it's looking back on it it's it was in a
very exciting time it was new territory
for everybody that was in that business
Alexa you obviously uh it was a while
before you got a first royalty check uh
and I just want to know what was it like
when you finally got paid for creating
this game and what was the like the
present that you bought yourself when
you could finally afford it I
well uh you know
I I could barely remember those the the
those shift to payments because because
what uh what that is brought to me that
time is kind of recognition and I had
lots of other titles at that time so I
started receiving my payments for my
other titles and and that is the dead
risk payments kind of embedded in all
this flu so that is that has made me
happy and and successful by by Glory at
the first step and with the funds what's
it what's the first thing that you
bought what was the first thing that you
bought saying like now I have enough
money is coming in I buy something
yeah he doesn't really buy a lot of
stuff clothes no I I had to twist his
arm to buy clothes yeah yeah I do
remember that that it was a very
successful year and I tried to finally
buy myself hand watch and they decided I
want to even look at the price I I will
take the the item I really love believe
it or not I bought 100
sake
[Laughter]
so I'm I'm not very good spender I would
I would put it this way on that note I
really want to say sincere congrats on
the movie and uh thank you for the
creation of the game and you guys have a
fantastic day